desde hace varios meses la segunda ola
del cómic 19 tiene a india sumida en la
adversidad hoy en día siguen siendo
detectados unos 200.000 casos al día y
los enfermos son cada vez más jóvenes
muchos son padres y sus hijos pueden
quedar entonces solos y vulnerables
para estos niños abandonados a su suerte
el gobierno indio tuvo que abrir
rápidamente centros de cuarentena
especiales este ha sido reservado para
niñas ocurridas recientemente en la
capital india
si una niña es encontrada abandonada a
su suerte debe ser admitir en el centro
de cuarentena durante 14 días antes de
que cualquier otro procedimiento se ha
iniciado
este centro de cuarentena no solo ofrece
un techo
las niñas cuentan con la alimentación
equilibrada seguimiento médico y
psicológico e incluso actividades
lúdicas
y por supuesto esta es la prueba de kobe
[Música]
alguien aquí ya se hizo la prueba
pero con frecuencia el virus es la
principal preocupación de muchos padres
perderán su empleo
lo que causará muchos problemas
financieros en la familia
entonces hay niños que empiezan a
trabajar
es uno de los riesgos
la escala de la catástrofe es de tal
magnitud que muchas familias sufrirán
a todo nivel y en todas las clases
sociales
algunos de estos niños serán reenviados
a sus casas pero la mayoría serán
transferidos a otros centros de acogida
la ong es ese pueblo de los niños maneja
una treintena de hogares en el país
tenemos muchos niños que perdieron a sus
padres debido al cobismo
llegan aquí deprimidos no saben cómo
sobrevivir es como si hubiesen perdido
su niñez
esta es la casa número 5 cuidada por
nuestra guardiana operativa con duro
aquí tenemos varios niños impactados por
el cob it
[Música]
entre estos niños que viven aquí cinco
hermanos perdieron hace un mes a su
único pariente por coronavirus
los huérfanos fueron encontrados errando
en las calles de nueva delhi
con la guía en autobús
y no
aquí todos los niños tienen algo que
hacer
cuando llegaron estaban en shock
hacemos de este lugar su hogar cuentan
con todo lo que necesitan un televisor
internet para estudiar libros y en
especial todos cuentan con una madre
sustituta aquí cada casa cuenta con su
mamá mujeres que son la esencia del
funcionamiento del albergue pero para
muchos actores del sector de la infancia
este tipo de instituciones no son la
mejor solución a largo plazo según
unicef en india y unos 30 millones de
niños abandonados o huérfanos medio
millón de estos niños ha sido conducido
a hogares especializados pero tan sólo
2.000 de ellos son legalmente adaptables
muchos hogares no integran a los niños
al sistema legal de adopción algunos
niños tienen padres o familiares y en
este caso hay que enviarlos
prioritariamente donde sus familias pero
en los centros de acogida también hay
niños abandonados o huérfanos sin ningún
familiar para cuidarlos estos niños son
los que deben ser acompañados para que
puedan ser adoptados legalmente
pero el mayor temor para todo el mundo
hoy en día es el tráfico de niños que
puede tener distintas formas el tráfico
sexual el trabajo infantil o las
adopciones ilegales durante las últimas
semanas en varias publicaciones con
fotos de huérfanos o para adoptar
acompañadas de números telefónicos le
han dado la vuelta a las redes sociales
estos mensajes podrían provenir de
buenos samaritanos pero mal informados
sobre el sistema de adopción legal sin
embargo los traficantes de niños también
usan este tipo de anzuelos con su ong
son al kapur trato de proteger a los
niños vulnerables ofreciéndoles apoyo
psicológico programas educativos y una
ayuda humanitaria
y que tuviste un auto
y sí
y lo que
la ong se enfoca en las familias indias
más pobres que viven en barrios de bajos
recursos de la capital
el objetivo es aliviar la miseria social
que conduce con frecuencia a abusos
contra los niños todos los días en al
menos uno de los barrios pobres en los
que intervenimos encontramos casos de
transacciones sexuales en la que los
niños son ofrecidos a cambio de comida
cada vez que un desastre golpea las
redes de traficantes se activan
inmediatamente antes de que el gobierno
la sociedad civil las ongs y los buenos
samaritanos puedan tener acceso a estos
niños los traficantes son quienes llegan
a los niños primero una situación de
urgencia que requiere de constante
vigilancia
para proteger a los niños expuestos a
los abusos y a los tráficos son anka pur
y su equipo tratan de apoyar a las
familias más frágiles
en india cientos de miles de personas
han muerto debido al hobby
pero otros millones aún sufren las
repercusiones económicas